[Music]
foreign
[Music]
jewelry I feel connected I go off in my
own world I guess I feel at peace I have
a lot of fun putting things together in
ways that are unexpected I like scale I
like color I like shapes I like textures
there's something really interesting
about how you can put things together in
ways that are surprising craving things
is like my life flow like that's what
makes me happy it's how I feel connected
back to everything else is by creating
foreign
[Music]
Harwell Godfrey and I am a fine jewelry
designer
Harwell Godfrey is known for its
maximalist kind of approach to jewelry
very colorful very intricate with
patterns a lot of details and I would
say geometric is also a word that comes
to mind I like fitting things together
in this geometric kind of pattern way
I talk a lot about my work being
inspired by the African diaspora I'm
certainly inspired by travel trips to
Morocco and India and you know places
where the handicrafts are just so robust
have certainly influenced the work that
I like to do
we are in my studio right now which is
in Northern California but I do a lot of
my production in New York that's kind of
the predominant place where production
happens and actually making the jewelry
the piece that I'm taking you through
are my five Stone totem drop Huggies
which is a pair of earrings and they're
very Jimmy they're long there's
different colors used in interesting
ways there's different types of stones
there's different shapes it's maximalist
it kind of goes back to all the things
that I love to do
I started with a sketch and I actually
sketched those out I find that my
greatest success comes when I'm as
specific as possible with them to
getting that end piece to look like what
I had in my head
and then from that point we take that
and we have a cad designer that we
really like to work with who gets our
work and and knows how we like things so
we get these files where you can turn
things around and look at them in 3D so
it gives me a really good sense then we
make either a silver casting or a wax
casting and for these we did silver so
it's very easy to like take those around
and like set stones into them and I also
Drew an inspiration for colors that I
wanted and I was like these are
generally speaking the colors that I
want but then I had to go and find those
stones to fit those colors and there was
like a price point that I'm trying to
hit so there's all these different
things that inform the stones so we had
to go out find the right sources for
those stones
[Music]
hi welcome good to see you too thank you
for having me I have different gem
dealers that I like to work with and I
feel like those relationships have
really you know developed over time and
and me like learning more about their
process and where things are coming from
and how they're sourcing and just kind
of seeing their overall you know what
they have to offer like maybe we do like
a big Stone up here here's a different
grain that's a little smaller yeah it's
quite a specimen so that would be really
incredible
sometimes people actually like reach out
to me and just introduce themselves so
they kind of come in from different
places but then over time as you work
with them and you see their goods and
you learn more about you know what
they're up to you figure out the ones
that like most closely align to my needs
from like the colors and the kinds of
stones and the scale the stones I like
to work with to you know does this fit
in with kind of the overall Vision that
I have for the brand and the types of
people that I want to work with and you
know support
think I am going to go with these
thank you
there are a lot of things that have
contributed to the person that I am now
um I was born and raised in Southern
California and my parents divorced when
I was young when I was four so I was
really raised predominantly by my mom
and my grandmother was very much around
so a lot of very strong women in the
house
my grandmother would wear jewelry every
day and in fact I have a ring that I
made that I'm wearing today that she
wore in a different form every day as a
cocktail ring I made it into a band that
I could stack with my wedding ring and
just kind of always think of her with it
I knew I wanted to do something in the
Arts I knew I wanted to get paid for it
and advertising felt like this really
great fit for me I worked in that
industry for 15 years I worked really
hard and I just realized that I had been
burning myself out for a long time and I
kind of hit a wall I knew that there are
other things inside of me creatively
that I wanted to explore that led me to
culinary school so this uh this Winding
Road of my careers and passions but I
wasn't figuring out what I could add to
that picture that was going to be
compelling and interesting and different
so I took a step back and made myself a
necklace and I made it out of leather
and crystals it was very like Festival
wear and I I wore it to a festival but
people saw and they thought it was
interesting and I started getting
requests for those necklaces there's
just something in how it made me feel
inside and how I felt working with those
materials and thinking in that way like
these little mini sculptures and that's
not a way I had ever really thought
before I really just felt myself so
compelled by it
typically when I have the castings and I
have the stones it goes into production
essentially and that means that it's
getting made and being assembled We
Gather the stones and then we move them
to our Setter there's nothing like
working with somebody who's you know a
master working with their hands it's
precious metals it's precious materials
it's soft Stones we need technical
Masters to be able to do this work and
that's what makes it fine jewelry
so once that um we get that seated in
there we get Hammer the wall over make
the stone tight
our Setter will receive those stones
those loose stones and our rough
castings and he will actually go to the
process of buffing them up a little bit
pre-polishing so that they're easier to
work with and those castings are
actually really rough at this point
they're gold but they're they're not at
all polished and they'll actually do
some pre-polishing so that they're
easier to work with and uses sandpaper
he has a rubber wheel just things to
clean it up a bit
once that's all done he'll start to get
ready to set that stone into that piece
so he uses a shellac stick and he makes
it to the exact right shape of the thing
we're working on get a nice and gooey so
it sticks
and
put it in place
I was prepared for us to put the stone
in
then after that casting is secured he'll
actually start setting the stone and
what he wants to do is take a little bit
of that bezel and like get a little lip
of it over each Stone so he uses a micro
hammer
once the stone is secured there's some
cleanup that has to happen because of
all that hammering so he actually uses a
tool that it's like an engraving tool
that cleans the wall of the bezel and he
actually has a way of buffing it so he
can buff out all of those like Hammer
marks they're small but they're there so
gotta clean those marks up once all
these pieces are put together we then
connect those jump rings to make the
earring like a whole piece and complete
and then finally if we actually do a
final polish to make the gold really
beautiful and sparkly
hi good to see you after production is
over and the earrings are done they come
back to me and I inspect them and just
get to see the final thing and make sure
it's it's what I had in my mind I know
so pretty very clean very nice
I love how the colors came together I
like that interplay of opaque versus
transparent we call these a totem
earring because I think there's
something totemesque about them the way
that they are these things that are
stacked up on top of each other in these
different and interesting shapes and
colors
I think designing jewelry has taught me
to really trust myself that's it's
really it's been an interesting process
because you truly are making something
for people to buy a specific thing and
when people get excited about that and
and connect to it
it's validating in the sense that you're
like oh wow you know I'm not crazy this
thing that I think is cool is cool and
interesting to someone else too
[Music]
I have always been interested in
philanthropy there's just something
about making something that's so you
know it's such a luxury good it's
expensive there's all these things and
yet the reality in our world is that
there are people suffering and and
hurting and so I felt like I had this
unique opportunity to take those luxury
goods that people were coveting and
actually turn that into money that I
could donate back to these organizations
so I actually donate 100 of the profits
from the charity Hearts is the
collection that I call it and um I don't
know this interesting collection of
people who seem to be getting behind it
which is cool Kamala Harris wearing my
NAACP heart it was super cool I chose
the NAACP is the charity that I wanted
to donate to because I believe in the
work that they're doing especially from
a legal standpoint and how important
that is to create you know an
environment where black Justice actually
comes to fruition Hilary Swank Blake
Lively actually did a lot to promote the
heart forever every town for gun safety
so did Julianne Moore the last one I
just introduced is for every town for
gun safety and as a mother and a human
and just a person who you know values
safety and wants everyone to be safe I
think we need to have common sense gun
laws
I think that giving back is just
something that again that I've believed
in for a really long time and and this
feels to me like the right way to do it
I know that this the stuff that I make
is not something that everyone can
afford and then I actually try to price
these particular pieces to be very
approachable for within the Fine Jewelry
luxury world so that I can sell you know
as many of them as I can and be able to
donate that money I feel like creating
and designing really brings me into the
thing I feel like I'm supposed to be
doing and there's something about that
that's really satisfying and I just feel
like I'm a part of something bigger when
I'm doing that work
[Music]